si la parole est à monsieur soilih pour
le groupe ump
merci monsieur le président chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre le recensement qui
réalisait à mayotte à un rythme
quinquennal ne plus en adéquation avec
le rythme de la croissance démographique
qui tend à exposer à une vitesse
incalculable est une indication ne
facilite guère la mise en oeuvre des
politiques publiques par rapport aux
réalités du terrain cinquante pour cent
de la population a moins de 25 ans 40%
de la population est en situation
irrégulière les mineurs isolés sur un
territoire exigu sont estimées à 3000
enfants dans 500 encore en grande
fragilité qu'a livrés à eux mêmes sont
les rapports du défenseur des droits
d'avril 2013 tous les rapports publiés
sur mayotte font un état d'un constat à
répétition à la menthe mayotte connaît
une délinquance et une insécurité
inquiétante
en voici donc quelques chiffres en
matière de délinquance et d'agressions
période 2012 2013
les atteintes volontaires à l'intégrité
physique sont chiffrées à 1363 en 2012
et 1398 en 2013 soit une hausse de 2,57
haussant les atteintes aux biens
représentent 4229 en 2012 et 4837 en
2013 soit une hausse de 14 38%
les escroqueries et infractions
économiques et financières sont de
l'ordre de 3 164 en 2012 est de 251 en
2013 soit une baisse enregistré de très
31,04 pourtant la délinquance juvénile
qui représente un total de 5 1956 en
2009 est en forte progression et passe à
6490 en 2013 soit une hausse de 8,4 26%
en matière d'immigration clandestine là
aussi les chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes
avec 13000 illégaux en un an selon le
figaro du 7 novembre 2013
avec bien sûr de le conduire au front
effectués systématiquement le bras de
mer séparant mayotte et en juin est
devenu le cra cimetière marin
mon cher qu'on pourrait en question s'il
vous plaît vous avez déjà rayer la
chronique en europe
monsieur le ministre il est fortement
regrettable de constater que des jeunes
mal servis sans emploi dans leur
majorité soit entraînée à des dérives de
délinquance mais face à ce fléau
d'insécurité grandissante
quelles sont donc monsieur le ministre
les mesures que le gouvernement propose
pour mayotte
merci très bien merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le sénateur swahili
poser des questions juste sur la
situation à mayotte et cela fait pas 18
mois il ya les problèmes de délinquance
de cambriolages et de violence sur votre
territoire et on peut polémiquer
ce que ne voulait pas d'ailleurs sur eux
les chiffres de la sécurité mais disons
clairement les choses
mayotte connaît une persistance de
certaines formes de délinquance
particulièrement inquiétante
vous connaissez aussi des problèmes de
violence scolaire qui interviennent aux
abords des établissements ou à
l'encontre des bus scolaires
elles sont le fait d'individus souvent
là aussi très jeune nous l'avons abordée
tout à l'heure à l'occasion de notre
question appâtés par le gain facile qui
agissent parfois en bande et les forces
de l'ordre ont déployé des dispositifs
régulier de sécurisation en conséquence
je rappelle aussi que la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière à mayotte fait
l'objet d'efforts soutenus que ce soit
par l'interpellation les étrangers en
situation régulière du contrôle des
documents d'identité ou la lutte contre
le travail illégal
je me rendrai le plus vite possible et
prochainement en tout cas à mayotte
comme je me suis rendu aux antilles il
ya quelques semaines la situation en
outre-mer fait l'objet de toute
l'attention du gouvernement car son rôle
nous l'avons évoqué pour d'autres
territoires c'est de garantir la
sécurité de nos concitoyens
sur l'ensemble du territoire de la
république ce dont mayotte a besoin
c'est la réussite de son projet de
départementalisation qui a été voté à
l'unanimité par notre parlement
et c'est sur tous les aspects économie
éducation
soutien l'administration lutte contre
l'émigration régulière lute contre la
sécurité que nous gagnerons en
efficacité et je compte m'appuyer non
seulement sur ce déplacement mais sur
les propositions
l'ensemble des élus du territoire merci
sur le sénateur très rapidement s'il
vous plaît la ministre ce qu'on avait
dit que vous viendrez à mayotte donc ça
sera l'occasion pour bien sûr de
disputer sur place les problèmes de
mayotte
merci